Your girlfriend is now your fiancee?
Yes.
Oh okay. So, how did you meet her?
I was in a concert in Buenos Aires,...
...and it was a very lucky thing I was introduced to her after.
I was in my hotel at a sort of VIP reception.
And she was a very famous actor there, so they brought her in.
And she wasn't, I don't think, very interested in meeting me.
And it just sort of happened.
And fate had it that we were introduced that night.
And you know, we became friends.
And then, the relationship began after that.
What do you think was the best present you gave to them?
I think the best present I ever gave was my love,...
...my attention every day.
I didn't save it for Valentine's Day.
I think that I got a lot of love to give, and...
...although I'm a pain in the ass and I'm not easy to live with,...
...I think that when I love you, I love you in a big way.